dans les eaux troubles de l'Atlantique
Nord un animal s'adapte discrètement à
de profonds changement de son
environnement c'est l'un des plus grands
prédateurs
du littoral
européen capable de chasser des proies
rapides et
[Musique]
fugaces le foc
gris on l'a souvent associé à une
adorable peluche blanche ou à un clown
de
mer et pourtant son destin est émaillé
d'épreuves
depuis toujours il doit faire face à des
super
prédateurs et depuis peu à des
[Musique]
cannibales aujourd'hui on le surprend à
remonter les rivières
ou à la chasse au
marsoin pour comprendre l'origine de ces
nouveaux comportements il faut musarder
à ses côtés au cœur d'un océan qui lui
aussi s'est
transformé
[Musique]
les rivages de l'Atlantique Nord
abritent les colonies de F
gris du Canada à la Suède en passant par
le Royaume-Uni ils affectionnent les EAU
tempétueuses et
tempéré
depuis la fin des années 70 et l'arrêt
de la chasse au foc la population
augmenta d'environ 10 % par
an mais depuis quelques années elle
plafonne aujourd'hui on commence tout
juste à comprendre l'origine de cette
stagnation grâce notamment au
recensement annuel et au progrès des
bagues et des balises
[Musique]
embarquées
on connaissait la plupart de ces
activités côtières on découvre désormais
ces déambulation au large ses zomes de
chasse et ses proies
[Musique]
inattendues
septembre un jeune mâle part en quête
d'une terre d'asile c'est c'estàdire le
plus souvent d'une des nombreuses îles
qui constellent les EAU du Royaume-Uni
où vivent 40 % de la population mondiale
et 95 % de la population européenne de
F parmi elles l'île de mai à l'est de
l'Écosse ce jeune Candide tente sa
chance un peu au
hasard mais cette île est déjà occupée
par un foc malâ de 270 kg qui règne
jalousement sur son
territoire le combat contre le poids
lourd est
inégal il va devoir partir à ailleurs
chercher une autre terre
d'accueil on pensait que les focques
étaient tous
philopatriques autrement dit qu'il
revenaient sur leur colonie natale pour
se reproduire mais les foc porteurs de
balises ou de bagues ont montré qu'il y
avait de nombreuses
exceptions ils ont notamment prouvé
qu'un jeune mâle est capable de nager
plus de 1000 km à la recherche d'une
nouvelle
colonie le jeune mâle tente de
s'approprier les meilleures îles des
reposoirs isolés jamais totalement
submergés d'autres foc ont évidemment eu
la même idée une explication musclée
avec le maître des lieux s'impose à
nouveau la vie d'un jeune mâle est assez
peu enviable pour trouver sa place en
société il doit affronter tous les mals
dominants des
îles s'il ne fait pas le poids il doit
abdiquer après avoir Eré plusieurs
semaines le jeune guerrier arrive enfin
à l'archipel des Orcades au nord de
l'Écosse en vue l'île de Westray ces
falaises semblent totalement
imprenables depuis le début de son
odyssée il aur allongé toute la côtest
du royaumuni et parcouru une distance
équivalente à un marathon par
jour pour arriver enfin sur l'îlo de
Fary dans une crique en apparence
déserte
en apparence seulement un autre combat
se profile mais ici son rival ne mesure
que 2 m pour 150
kg victoire
durement
acquise à son tour il va défendre son
lopan TER tout en
jeunant son
ambition se
reproduire une semaine après son combat
triomphal il est récompensé par
l'arrivée de femelle qu'il va prendre
sous sa
protection plus petite plus fine plus
blanche et plus
coquette
le voici Pacha à la tête d'un harême de
se irrésistibles femelles grasses et
morveuse pendant 6 semaines il doit les
surveiller
jalousement pour veiller à ce que
d'autres malâ ne viennent pas empiéter
sur son territoire et son harme il
s'escrime à les tenir à
l'écart sur de courtes distan ilut aussi
vite qu'un homme qui
[Musique]
court
de l'âge de 10 ans jusqu'à leur mort
vers 25 ans les malfo gris doivent se
livrer à une vingtaine de combats chaque
automne rarement mortel ces
affrontements laissent au combattants
des cicatrice
àe quant aux femelles elles ne sont pas
arrivé
seul fécondé il y a 11
mois viennent ici mtre bas les foces
gris sont les plus grands animaux
sauvages qui se reproduisent à terre au
Royaume-Uni curieusement il naît chaque
année 10 femelles pour SEP mâles ses
demi-frères et sœurs sont nés à quelques
jours
d'intervalle leur manteau blanc leur
vaut le surnom de
Blanchon les blanchons ne suscitent
aucun instinct paternel chez le mâle qui
ne participe jamais à leur
éducation quant à la femelle elle ne
s'occupe des blanchons que pendant les
18 jours que dure l'allitement son
secret un des laits les plus gras du
monde 5 L de lait qui permettent au
petit de gagner 2 kg par jour un
véritable régime de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sumo
les blanchons épuisent leur mè qui
perdent jusqu'à 6 kil par jour et 40 %
de leur poids en moins de 3 semaines
d'allaitement toutes les nuits de
novembre c'est le baby boom dans les
maternités
insulaires sur l'île de Far ce sont
environ 12000 F gris qui s'entass sur
les plages à l'automne c'est la seconde
plus grande colonie du
Royaume-Uni
[Musique]
depuis 2008 la population de cette île
ne croit que d'environ 4 % par an soit
près de trois fois moins que dans les
années
80 pourtant les femelles sont toujours
aussi fécondes et donnent naissance à
une douzaine de petits dans leur vie les
blanchons seraient donc victime d'une
surmortalité à partir du moment où ils
quitent le confort des
maternité après de semaines passées dans
les souilles de Bou à l'abri des
tempêtes certaines femelles les invitent
à découvrir les joies des premiers bains
elles savent être
persuasives omnubilés par leur mamell
les petits oublient qu'ils pénètrent
pour la première fois dans l'eau glacée
une méthode pédagogique très
[Musique]
efficace
les mères incitent même leur rocheton à
nager en les forçant à immerger la tête
sous
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
peu isolé du froid les blanchons
prennent d'abord des bains de courte
durée puis s'aventure seul et plus
longtemps
insouciant du danger d'un nouveau
danger un Mâ
adulte auè le soin de le
[Musique]
repousser
en regroupant leur petits en crèche les
femelles coalisé parviennent à juguler
les ardeurs du
malâ malgré la différence de taille ce
sont elles qui contrôlent le calendrier
de reproduction sur
l'île après précisément 18 jours
d'allaitement à jeun les femelles ne
produisent plus assez de lait les petits
vont devoir être
sevrés premier signe de leur
émancipation
laamue les blanchons vont perdre
progressivement leur fourrure
immaculée pour réussir à s'en
débarrasser tous les moyens sont
[Musique]
bons
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps certaines femelles
affamées regagnent l'océan pour se
nourrir leurs petits ne les reverront
probablement
[Musique]
jamais les voilà seul livrés à eux-mêmes
au cœur de
l'hiver orphelin des
tempêtes un petit sur deux ne survit pas
à ce traitement de
choc pire depuis quelques années ils
doivent faire face à un ennemi
intime un malâ
cannibal
[Musique]
il compte uniquement sur son poids pour
terérasser ses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
proies
[Musique]
sa mère encore à proximité entend son
cri de détresse
elle fait
diversion
miraculeusement le jeune Fox s'en sort
avec quelques
[Musique]
blessures mal cannibal reprend sa
chasse il guidete le départ des mes pour
s'en prendre à des petits
isolés cette fois rien ne peut le
[Applaudissements]
distraire ce comportement a été observé
depuis le début des années 2000 sur
plusieurs îles britanniques chaque fog
cannibal tue environ 12 petit
par curieusement il ne prélève qu'un
lambau de gras avant d'abandonner leur
victime on pense que ce cannibalisme est
moins provoqué par la faim que par une
frustration sexuelle en effet leur
stratagème ressembl étrangement à celui
m au point par des jeunes mâles leur
cible les jeunes femelles qui tentent de
regagner
l'île sûr de leur supériorité physique
Estelle des cannibales ils vont de les
immobiliser à faible
profondeur
pincé et mordu à la nuque les femelles
ne peuvent plus s'enfuir le F est adepte
de
l'amourvache les Mâ pourrai dévorer leur
partenair mais leur objectif est tout
autre s'accoupler pour assurer leur
descendance ces jeunes foc sont
surnommés les mâles périphériques on
estime qu'ils ont 10 fois moins de
chance de se reproduire que les grands
mâles mais comme ils sont plus nombreux
ils parviennent souvent à leur
fin
décembre marque la fin de la saison des
accouplements toutes les femelles ont
quitté l'île seul reste en marude
quelques malâ
[Musique]
solitaire c'est le moment choisi par les
derniers orphelins pour prendre le
large affronter les tempêtes et
l'inconnu depuis toujours le calendrier
de reproduction du f gris semble
paradoxal en effet c'est en plein hiver
que les petits sont sevrés et se
retrouvent livrés à eux-mêmes pour faire
face à la violence des éléments au
vagues et depuis quelques années au
mâles qui ont pris goût à la VI de
F les petits doivent tromper la
surveillance du foc cannibal pour gagner
le
[Musique]
large ils
improvisent certains vont chercher des
crevasses pour s'échapper
[Musique]
discrètement
victoire ces failles offrent des sorties
dérobé vers le
large
[Musique]
ce dernier foc aura-t-il cette
chance
[Musique]
ce jeune F n'est pas parvenu à semer le
cannibal
que prépare ce mâle un baiser de Juda ou
une farce de
clown ni l'un ni l'autre dans l'eau le
tueur ne peut utiliser son poids pour
saisir et croquer les
[Musique]
petits ce jeûne est passé
vers un océan
déchaîné son sort sera scellé par les
colères de
l'hiver ce candide doit survivre au cœur
des montagnes liquides où les poissons
sont encore
rares
pendant les premiers mois de leur vie
aquatique les foc voi fondre leur
réserve de graisse au contact de l'eau
froide comme cette jeune femelle ses
parents ne lui ont jamais appris à
chasser que va-t-elle bien pouvoir se
mettre sous la
[Musique]
dent une algue laminaire la salade de la
mer du
Nord pas très
[Musique]
nourrissant mais jusqu'au printemps elle
peut compter sur sa réserve de pour lui
permettre de survivre en économisant ses
[Musique]
stocks comme l'eau froide brûle les
graisses plus rapidement que l'air les
jeunes foc effectuent de nombreux
séjours à terre pour préserver leur
réserves en moyenne ils passent 4 jours
en mer pour un jour à
terre ils apprennent d'instinct à se
servir de leur
sens leur vue sensible aux basses lumièr
tant sous l'eau que sur l'eau
elle leur permet de détecter les mal
suspects qui
Rudent le Rora qui depuis leur naissance
distingue l'odeur spécifique à chaque
F enfin un sens du toucher à distance
grâce à leur vibrce c'est-à-dire leur
moustache ell sont 10 fois plus sensible
que celle des
chats même dans l'obscurité elle capte
les ondes créées par les corps en
mouvement ces ondes ne sont pas celles
produites par un mal en
maroue cette barigue de graisse profite
des joies d'une talasothérapie à l'eau
froide tout en dormant ce mâle régule sa
température en maintenant son corps
immergé dans l'eau glacée le jeun F peut
donc aiser Tromp sa vigilance et en
apparence La voix est Libre plus d'ondes
suspecte c'est le moment idéal pour
prendre le
large pourtant son noui détecte
d'étrangees sifflement de plus en plus
présent venant de toutes les directions
et mélangé à des
[Musique]
cliquetis la baleine
tueuse venu en famille chasser le
[Musique]
foc les plus expérimentés donne loisir
aux plus jeunes de s'entraîner à
assommer le
[Musique]
foc avant de partager le repas en
famille
depuis la nuit des temps les balenueuses
également appelés orque chassent le foc
celle de l'Atlantique Nord consomme
aussi du poisson mais comme cette
ressource tend à s'amenuiser elle se
rabattent sur les foces on les observe
de plus en plus souvent après des
côtes aussi tous les foc jeunes ou
adultes doivent apprendre à vivre avec
leurs sombres
menaces celui qui a échappé à une
attaque d'orque c'est les repérer à
distance même en
dormant en gonflant ses poumons le fog
fait la bouteille il ne se repose que
d'un œil pendant ses odyssées ses
vibriss détecte toute vibration
inhabituelle en surface et de l'autre
côté du
miroir son noui plus sensible dans l'eau
que dans l'air identifie de loin les
de son ennemi
[Musique]
mortel la simple vue de l'aileron dorsal
terrorise tous les f et pour cause sous
ce couteau noir d' M8 pour le mal adulte
se cache un prédateur de 9
tonnes pire les or chass me sont
capables de pote de vitesse à 70
km/h les foc ne peuvent
rivaliser seul salut possible
rassemblement sur un abri de
fortune pour attraper les foc les orques
ne peuvent s'échouer sur ces rochers
coiffés de coquillage ils déchiquetterai
leur
épiderme
elle tente alors de brouiller les pistes
les femelles et les jeunes restent sous
la surface et Chang rapidement de
position pendant que le mâle se montre
ostensiblement pour effrayer les
foc
en vain les foc ne bougent
pas aussi les orques préfèr passer leur
chemin pour tenter de surprendre
ailleurs des jeunes fogs
imprudents
les orques apparaissent exclusivement à
la fin du printemps et en été au nord du
Royaume-Uni pour une bonne raison ce
calendrier correspond au moment où les
focques sont les plus
gras à la fin du printemps tous les foc
ont quitté la maternité de faray et pour
cause
le retour du soleil déclenche dans la
mer du Nord une explosion de vie donc de
proie disponible pour les
foces la lumière stimule l'explosion de
phytoplantcton des algues microscopiques
qui donnent aux eau de surface leur
teinte émaudde des algues qui vont à
leur tour nourrir des petits poissons
écrustacés eux-mêmes mangés par des
prédateurs dans les 3 ans qui suivent le
départ de leur île natale les jeunes foc
partent en quête de ses proies au hasard
des courants sans por d'attache il se
dispersent ainsi en quittant far un F a
d'abord visité la pointe nord de
l'Écosse en passant dans le détroit du
Pentland first et s remarquables
aiguilles de gris rouge des étranges
formations géologiques rongé par la mer
et le
[Musique]
vent
puis il a fait demi-tour et le cap au
Sud en s'aventurant le long de la côte
ouest de
l'Écosse comme il n'a jamais reçu de
leçon de chasse de ses parents il
navigue à l'instinct en observant ses
semblables ou d'autres animaux
marins promesse de
festin
[Musique]
parmi ces meilleurs indicateurs les fot
basson ces patrouilles de kamicaz
repèent leur victime sous la
surface avant de fondre sur elle en
piqué jusqu'à l'incroyable vitesse de
[Musique]
kmh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec les Goélan et autres oiseaux marins
le Fox s'invite à la table des fous et
finit les restes du banquet son instinct
ne l'a pas
[Musique]
trompé
au fil des rencontres ce foc aura nagé
plus de 1000 km en 3 ans pour finalement
atteindre le pays de gale et l'île de
Rams
elle est séparée de la terre par un isme
étroit en forme d'antau noir où
s'engouffr des violents courants créés
par les flux de
Maré il draent des EAU froides et des
nutriments venus des profondeurs
24 he sur 24 ils assurent une livraison
de nourriture pour des centaines de
prédateurs marins réunis dans la
passe parmi eux un petit set assz furtif
le
marsoin ce bolide de 60 kg déjoue la
force du courant de ramse pour attraper
plus de 5 kg de poisson par
jour depuis quelques années on aarqué
MalF gris sintéress de près à ces cass
côtiers bien qu'à l'aise dans le courant
le fog gris ne peut rivaliser de vitesse
avec les marsoins toute course poursuite
etoué à
l'échec alors il utilise une autre
stratégie le F imite celle des grands
félins pour surprendre ses proies la
chasse en
embuscade problème la visibilité ne
dépasse pas quelques mètres et l'empêche
de chasser à vue heureusement ces vibr
sont plus sensibles aux ondes créées par
des corps en mouvement dans l'eau que
dans l'air
elles agissent comme un sondeur
multifessau et donne des informations
sur la position le sens de déplacement
et la vitesse des
marsoins ainsi au cœur de la passe et
son trafic incessant de marsoin le foc
attend le passage de sa proie pour
tenter de la surprendre et
l'intercepter
en vain il manque encore de pratique
pourtant ici et dans d'autres goulet de
l'océan Atlantique des focques mâles
dévorent désormais plus d'une dizaine de
marsoins par
an on n'a jamais encore observé
d'attaque de marsoin par des femelles on
pense qu'elle se concentre sur des
proies plus
petites ainsi en quête de nourriture une
femelle a quitté l'île de faray pour
rejoindre les rivages des îles
shetlandes curieusement les apnées des
femelles sont en moyenne plus longues
mais moins profondes que celles des
mâles 6 contre 5 minutes et 48 contre 57
m conséquence les femelles chassent
essentiellement à proximité des côte
pour chercher leur
pitance ainsi au sud-ouest des îles
Shetland la femelle affectionne les
plages de sable blanc notamment celle de
l'île de
saintignan au cœur de ces ba abrités se
cachent des poissons
invisibles les rois du
camouflage qui ne résistent pas au
peiges de ces
vibriss
[Musique]
des
limandes g Goan qui viendrait jouer les
picassiett
[Musique]
les femelles commencent à enfanter dès
l' de 4 ans et doivent donc commencer
très jeune à se constituer des réserves
de
grisse à la recherche de nouveau
territoires de chasse ces femelles et
tous les foges gris découvrent désormais
un nouveau
monde un océan étrange peuplé de Boué
coloré comme des ballons de
beudruche et de monstres en acier qui
ronronnent au cœur de gradin en béton
Garn de
éan bref un océan transformé dans lequel
doivent désormais évoluer tous les
prédateurs de
l'Atlantique même les
orques à la découverte de ce monde
étrange deux foc ont quitté ensemble far
é longongé la côteste de l'Écosse
jusquen
[Musique]
Angleterre ils s'aperçoivent que
d'autres foges gris ne s'émeuffent pas
de la présence d'étranges géants d'acier
qui peuple ces eau
troubles
[Musique]
en remontant la rivière tise les foc
rencontrent un monde de métal et de
béton qui fume et bourdonnent au rythme
des marées et des
[Musique]
voitures ils ne sont pas les seuls à
nager à contrecourant à la marée
montante les saumons atlantiques
remontent le flux dans l'espoir
trouverel frayre celle où ils sont nés
avec le très développé ils sont aimantés
par des effflu diffus l'odeur propre à
la
rivière les f espère évidemment pouvoir
se repêre de ces
[Musique]
poissons mais il reste insaisissable en
pleine
eau par chance l'homme et son goût
immodéré pour le béton et le métal vont
leur donner un petit coup de
pouce en amont des Boué les focques ont
découvert un mur totalement
infranchissable un
barrage le courant de la marée montante
draîne d'autres focques qui convergent
vers l'entonnoir en
béton tous attendent l'ouverture des
vannes l'eau douce déversée fera monter
en surface les saumons pressé de pondre
en
amont pour le bonheur des
[Applaudissements]
foces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour d'été les foc dévorent moins
de 7 % des saons qui tentent de franchir
le
barrage en montant la mer finit par
compenser le courant de la rivière et
engloutit les vannes les saumons peuvent
alors aisément rejoindre leur frayère en
amont du
barrage quant au foc et notamment cette
femelle ils peuvent enfin digérer leurs
repas et se délasser dans un bain
[Musique]
moussant une femelle F gris consomme en
moyenne 2 kg demi de poisson par jour
contre TR pour un mâle et plus le
poisson est gras moins il en faut or les
saons sont gras et nourrissant à souhait
mais pas toujours aussi facile à
capturer comme va le découvrir une
femelle qui s'est aventurée en Écosse
elle a découvert des rangées d'étranges
structures cylindriqu les fermes à
[Musique]
saumon 10 cages de 40 m de diamètre
elles enferment plus d'un million de
[Musique]
saumons
des fruits défendus qui restent
inaccessibl au
[Musique]
foc au total il y a désormais près de
350 fermes à saumon au Royaume-Uni
essentiellement en Écosse et dans ces
îles ces cages créent des écosystèmes
miniatures à plusieurs centaines de
mètres à la ronde les farines les
excréments et les parasites nourrissent
de nombreux poissons qui vivent à
l'extérieur des
cages comme ces lieux les foc peuvent
parfaitement s'en
[Musique]
contenter
mais les exploitants des fermes ne font
pas de différence entre un F qui chasse
les lieux autour des cages et un voleur
de
saumon les poissons d'élevage restent la
propriété de l'homme qui se donne tous
les moyens pour les
protéger
les foc paient le prix fort pour leur
curiosité au Royaume-Uni la loi autorise
l'abattage des foces soupçonnés de
chaparder des poissons
d'élevage rien ne les prépare à cette
justice
[Musique]
expéditive en mer Baltique sur le
littoral de la Suède les pêcheurs
entrent également en conflit avec les
foces dans les années 2000 ils ont
inventé des pièges qui sont formés d'un
filet qui barre la route au poisson
côtier puis d'un Enton noir en filet qui
les font converger vers une
[Musique]
nasse dans leur siage ils ent traînent
les
foc quelques caméras de surveillance les
surprennent en flagrant délit de vol de
saumon de Moru et de
[Musique]
Haran en remontant leur piège les
pêcheurs ne collectent souvent que les
miettes des repas des
les stocks de poissons de la Baltique
sont surexploités et
samenuis inévitablement les fes gris
deviennent les coupables tout trouvés de
cette
surpêche leur population sont sévèrement
impacté par des morts accidentelles dans
les filets et des abattages
autorisés depuis le début du 20e siècle
la moitié des effectifs de la mer
Baltique a
[Musique]
disparu
aujourd'hui à l'image de celle des
autres F gris de l'Atlantique Nord la
population de fluctue essentiellement au
rythme des ressources alimentaires
disponible des nouveaux
prédateurs et des mortalités
accidentelles autant de facteurs qui
expliquent la stagnation de leur
population il y a aujourd'hui moins de F
gris que d'éléphants d'Afrique mais
comme ils sont concentrés sur les
rivages de l'Atlantique Nord il donnent
l'impression de prospérer au contact des
engins de pêche de nombreux foges
disparaissent en mer sans laisser de
trace certains survivent comme cette
femelle réchapper miraculeusement des
mailles d'un
filet sur l'origine des prédations sur
les proies inhabituelles on ne peut que
spéculer mais les soupçons portent
encore sur l'industrie de la
pêche en prélevant les ressources
disponibles elle force les foc à trouver
d'autres sources de
protéines pour survivre dans cet océan
transformé les futures générations de F
devront à leur tour adapter leur
déplacement et
[Musique]
comportement les fques aujourd'hui
martyrisé dans le nord du Royaume-Uni
s'installent plus au sud notamment à
blackne
point sur ces rivages nul orque et nul
piège ou ferme à Saumont un nouvel
eldorado où les foces sont intégralement
protégés alors qu'ils y ont été décimés
dès le 19e siècle ici naissait 25 petits
en 2001 aujourd'hui c'est plus de 2000
blanchons qui viennent au monde chaque
année pour créer la plus grande colonie
de reproduction de
l'Angleterre preuve qu'un peu de poisson
et de protection suffisent au fog gris
pour prospérer un message assez simple
pour qui veut bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'entendre
[Musique]